herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauer bei
aller deutschland schön dass sie mit
dabei sind auch heute wieder mit einem
corona kompakt zu den wichtigsten
entwicklungen und hintergründen und mit
antworten auf ihre fragen
für die ist heute professor dr henrik
strikt vom uniklinikum bonn mit dabei
zunächst aber erstmal das neueste von
heute es gibt nämlich eine erste
ausgangssperre
das corona virus breitet sich weiter in
rasantem tempo aus die bayerische stadt
mitterteich hat daher jetzt
deutschlandweit die erste offizielle
ausgangssperre verhängt sie gilt bis zum
zweiten april eine drastische aber
scheinbar notwendige maßnahme wir haben
nun 47 bestehende fälle
wir haben 15 patienten in krankenhäusern
davon neun aus mitterteich und fünf
patienten befinden sich in beatmung 6500
einwohner dürfen das haus nur noch
verlassen wenn es unbedingt notwendig
ist
arztbesuche arbeiten oder einkaufen sind
erlaubt lebensmittel horten muss also
niemand diese ausgangssperre werde nicht
einhalt begeht eine straftat nach
paragraf 55 und 70
infektionsschutzgesetz die mit bis zu
zwei jahren haft oder oder goldstadt
bewertet ist während die menschen in
mitterteich zuhause festsetzen hoffen
urlauber auf mallorca endlich nach hause
zurück zu können seit tagen dürfen sie
ihre hotels nicht mehr verlassen jetzt
schließen diese ganz nun warten hunderte
rückreisende an den check-in-schaltern
mit gebührendem sicherheitsabstand und
in der hoffnung auf ein rückflugticket
viele flüge sind gestrichen jeder nimmt
was er kriegen kann
ich würde theoretisch nach düsseldorf
fliegen aber ich muss jetzt hamburg
nehmen meine großmutter spiegel mutter
bis 82 und da hat man ständig nach hause
telefoniert dass sie wirklich vorsichtig
sein soll weil man wusste wie das hier
sein gang genommen hat und das weiß man
dass das dann in seiner heimat nicht
anders um und die aktuellen zahlen
verdeutlichen es in deutschland gibt es
heute mit 13 1979 infizierten knapp 4000
neuinfektionen seit gestern und 31 tote
um gefährdete menschen zu schützen haben
erfurter studenten ehrenamtlich den
corona kurier service ins leben gerufen
damit beispielsweise ältere menschen
gerade jetzt nicht in volle supermärkte
müssen neben studenten bestellungen am
telefon auf rund 1 probt mit körnern ich
bräuchte dann noch ihre adresse ganz
wichtig sind wir im moment
semesterferien das heißt wir haben zeit
und da haben wir gedacht das ist eine
gute sache da machen wir auch mal was
sinnvolleres als jetzt nur uns zuhause
einzusperren und können vielleicht den
leuten helfen die das dringender
brauchen
eingekauft wird per lastenfahrrad die
ware wird direkt vor die haustüre gelegt
lebensmittellieferungen benötigen
weiterhin auch hunderte autofahrer die
bereits die dritte nacht in folge auf
der a4 richtung polen im stau stehen
jetzt rückte sogar die bundeswehr an um
helfer vor ort zu unterstützen
wir haben die fahrzeuge die mit kinder
in zossen haben wir ausgelobt haben wir
direkt zur grenze gebracht damit direkt
abgefertigt werden aber der verkehr
nimmt nicht ab die erste fahrer fährt
schon realisiert das ist gesundheitlich
nicht gutgeht auslöser für den stau sind
corona bedingte strenge
gesundheitskontrollen bei der einreise
nach polen die situation bleibt weiter
angespannt
während unser experte wollte für corona
kompakt ist doch professor doktor
hendrik strickt er leitet das institut
für virologie am universitätsklinikum
bonn sind ja auch da direkt im labor und
sie waren damit auch zuständig in bonn
für den besonders betroffenen kreis
heinsberg und durch die betreuung vieler
infizierter dort haben sie auch dann als
erster neue symptome entdeckt bei
komapatienten welche waren sind das
schönen guten tag also wir haben nur zum
teil um das klarzustellen nur zum teil
die diagnostik für das gesundheitsamt
gemacht aber wir sind rausgerückt um
bisschen auch zu verstehen was du die
milderen symptomatiken sind gar nicht
die schweren fälle den krankenhäusern
sind und was uns aufgefallen ist dass
viele berichten dass sie einen verlust
vom geruch und geschmack hatten aber so
deutlich dass man unter der dusche nicht
mehr das shampoo gerochen hat oder die
krankenschwester beim windelwechseln die
windeln nicht mehr gebrochen hat und das
dann auch selber mit essigessenz
getestet hat ihr geruchssinn ist das
gibt aber auch ein paar es waren 70
prozent die das berichtet haben es gibt
ein bisschen ahnung aber das scheint so
eine kurze phase nur zu sein wo das ist
von zwei drei tagen
und dann kommt der geruchs dann auch
wieder aber wir fanden es spannend dass
es dann doch so spezifische symptome und
eigenartiges symptome im vergleich zur
grippe geld das stimmt auf jeden fall es
gibt noch weitere erkenntnisse von ihnen
vielen dank für den moment wir sprechen
uns dann wieder mit den fragen der
zuschauer also bis später eine frage die
ich persönlich habe wenn ich bilder von
menschengruppen in der sonne see und
davon höre dass teilweise sogar noch
kneipen geöffnet haben
warum haben inzwischen nicht wirklich
alle verstanden worum es geht nämlich
auf distanz gehen abstand halten
kontakte reduzieren und so gut es
irgendwie klappt zu hause bleiben aber
funktioniert nicht überall
seit tagen ist schulfrei in potsdam
damit die schüler nicht sich selber und
andere mit corona infizieren
doch an vielen stellen der stadt ziehen
sie heute gemeinsam durch den sonnigen
tag hier verkündet ein schild das
betrieb und nutzung von spiel- und
sportanlagen seit drei tagen verboten
sind
die skate rampe ist zusätzlich mit einem
bauzaun abgesperrt vergebens in münchen
schlägt der polizeisprecher heute mittag
alarm wegen ganz ähnlicher bilder im
münchner osten
wo tatsächlich einfach bis zu zwei
personen auf spielplätzen sind dass das
extrembeispiel ist ein skaterpark wo
tatsächlich 200 personen sind darunter
alleine 40 kinderwagen und das zeigt
einfach die wenig sensibilität
tatsächlich für die grundsätzliche
problem stellung besteht momentan in
unserer gesellschaft herrscht nämlich
dass wir kontakt vermeiden müssen auch
manche gastronomiebetriebe in münchen
sollen sich anders als diese hier nicht
an die aktuellen vorgaben halten
insgesamt ist das leben in vielen teilen
von münchen deutlich ruhiger als sonst
die menschen hoffen
man sollte schon ein bisschen
solidarität zeigen und das werde ich
selber auch machen also ich versuche
mich auch daran zu halten
ich bin auch im home office ich würde
mich sehr freuen wenn wir keine
ausgangssperre kriegen weil jeder
vernünftig ist und einfach sagt ich
mache jetzt nicht party weil es mir
scheiß ich alles so zu sagen sorry für
scheiße aber es ist halt so
ja ich habe mama die ist 81 und ich will
die nicht irgendwie in zwei wochen oder
in drei wochen auf dem krankenhausflur
verdecken sie in ehrlich gesagt ja
die münchner polizei kann nicht überall
kontrollieren ohne die einsicht der
menschen funktioniert es nicht
die mechanik die dahinter steht ist
letzten endes die das tatsächlich die
situation für viele wirklich noch nicht
greifbar ist greifbar im sinne von mir
fehlt ja nichts ein geht es gut da
draußen wo ist das problem und da müssen
wir noch wirklich hinkommen das
tatsächlich all jene menschen momentan
tatsächlich unter der großen
leichtfertigkeit versuche normalität
abzubilden verstehen dass diese normale
situation im moment halt nicht da ist
vor allem in den städten kommt es
momentan zu sehr viel mehr direkten
menschlichen kontakten als unbedingt
notwendig weil bestehende
einschränkungen nicht eingehalten werden
die stadt potsdam heute nachmittag die
komplette schließung des volksparks
verfügt mit dem hinweis dass härtere
maßnahmen folgen wenn sich die menschen
nicht freiwillig beschränken und
woanders da genügen noch ein paar meter
hiervon um die distanz zu sichern mit
solchen flatterband nämlich oder
woanders mit plastikfolie
da wird seit einigen tagen nämlich der
fahrerbereich in den bussen abgesperrt
um so den nötigen
stand zu den fahrgästen zu sichern das
ist nicht die einzige besonderheit im
öffentlichen nahverkehr gerade
verbarrikadiert hinter flatterband die
fahrer der kölner verkehrsbetriebe
setzen auf abstand
ihre fahrgäste würden das auch gerne tun
in den zeiten des virus würde ich
natürlich gerne mehr schütze ich muss
nur zur arbeit versuche jedenfalls mich
nicht mehr festzuhalten ich direkt in
die bahn gesetzt michael ich versuche
abstand zu halten von den anderen aber
das gelingt nicht immer weil viele
uneinsichtig sind und dahin ich trage
mein muss es dabei keine schlechte idee
in den öffis kommt man sich nahe wir nur
noch an wenigen orten zurzeit die bauern
vor einstieg im bus nur noch hinten um
die fahrer vor kontakten zu schützen und
künftig gilt in kölner reduzierte
samstagsfahrplan der grund dafür ist
dass wir gemerkt haben dass in den
letzten tagen und wochen die zahl der
fahrgäste deutlich zurückgegangen ist
unsere busse und bahnen sind extrem
deutlich leerer als sonst in den
spitzenzeiten am morgen zum beispiel
voran sogar mehr züge und busse als
sonst da gibt es weniger gedränge solche
bilder aber sieht man bei uns nicht in
japan desinfizieren wie die züge nicht
sinnvoll sagen dagegen unsere
verkehrsunternehmen also wir können
keinen wirksamen schutz unserer
fahrgäste gewährleisten das ist einfach
nicht machbar
wir können wir haben jeden tag um mehr
als 600 bus und bahn im einsatz wie
können wir nicht permanent desinfizieren
das schaffen wir einfach nicht zumal ja
auch die wirkung relativ schnell wieder
verpufft wäre wenn
gewisse anzahl von fahrgästen wieder in
den barden drin ist doch die angst der
fahrgäste bedroht inzwischen erste
verkehrsunternehmen wie das start up
pinkus gestartet erst vergangenen sommer
der fahrbetrieb wird vorläufig
eingestellt
als junges unternehmen und start up
bedeutet das natürlich ja maximal
existenzängste ich denke das geht allen
jungen unternehmen kleinunternehmen
gerade so wir müssen schauen was wir auf
kurzarbeit gehen
weiteres opfer der korona krise die
umstrittene düsseldorf war umwelt spur
hier sollten nur räder busse und autos
fahren um die abgasbelastung zu senken
jetzt dürfen wieder alle jetzt haben wir
das phänomen im zuge der korona krise
wollen wir dass menschen gerade nicht
den öpnv benutzen denn die das
ansteckungsrisiko in einer bahn in einem
bus ist naturgemäß höher als wenn man
allein in seinem pkw sitzt die botschaft
raus aus dem bus die krise beschert den
verkehrsbetrieben verluste auf diese mit
kürzung ihrer fahrpläne reagieren und
damit jetzt noch einmal zur professor dr
hendrik strikt dem leiter des instituts
für virologie am universitätsklinikum in
bonn herrscht krieg sie haben auch
geradezu geguckt was es ihr denn ihr
expertentipps sollte man noch busfahren
bahnfahren in diesen zeiten oder besser
gar nicht also ich kann da weder zu-
noch abgeraten das ist eben genau das
problem was wahrscheinlich viele
menschen haben
man soll den abstand halten wenn man
einen bus benutzen
muss und brach ein bus braucht dann
sollte man auch den bus benutzen
natürlich sie haben ihre arbeit im labor
unterbrochen um die fragen unserer
zuschauer zu beantworten dritter kumpel
zum beispiel hat geschrieben
sie fragt wie sieht's mit spazierengehen
aus wenn man durch ein waldstück läuft
und menschenansammlung meidet geht das
also alleine einen spaziergang im wald
das ist gut für das für den körper gut
für den geist gut für das immunsystem
natürlich geht das und man sollte auch
solche sachen auf keinen fall verzichten
das ist eine gute nachricht man muss
eben den abstand waren haben wir ja
nicht überall gesehen bisher aber das
klappt hoffentlich noch besser isabel
fragt ich bin jung und gesund ergibt es
sinn mich bei meinem freund bewusst
anzustecken in quarantäne zu gehen und
somit dann hoffentlich immun zu werden
nein das ist unverantwortlich weil auch
wenn wir von statistiken reden dass zb
die älteren menschen mehr betroffen sind
als jüngere können auch jüngere menschen
spielt mal schwere verläufe man kann so
was nicht ausschließen
und viel schlimmer ist auch noch dass
man seine eltern großeltern unbewusst
anstecken kann ohne dass man es
eigentlich wollte also klare daraus
abraten dazu sybille hat uns auch
gemailt hilft der besuch in der eigenen
sauna gegen viren oder eine wärmekabine
wenn man den einen hat
also eine sauna hilft jetzt nicht
unbedingt gegen viren
dann könnte man sehr lange auch darüber
reden aber was man vorher gemacht hat
was einem gut getan hat was dem körper
gut getan hat was einem belebt hat
darauf sollte man jetzt auch nicht
verzichten
also wahrscheinlich auch ganz wichtig in
diesen tagen dass man trotz aller
distanz und zu hause bleiben nicht
vergisst dass es einmal wirklich gut
gehen muss und man sich jetzt nicht
komplett von allen los sagt was eben im
bereich des möglichen ist auch zum
beispiel zeitungen lesen nicht burkhard
w der frage nämlich bringt das etwas
zeitungen in die mikrowelle zu legen und
einige zeit zu bestrahlen wozu auch
immer ja dahinter steckt wahrscheinlich
die sorge dass auf zeitungen vielleicht
viren liegen könnten vom postboten oder
vom zeitungsboten das während mini auch
wenn addieren wären wir haben das
minimale anteile von viren wir wissen
dass die auf papier sich sowieso nicht
lange halten können
und bevor man die wohnung in brand setzt
rate ich wirklich dazu ab die zeitung in
die h m mikrowelle zu legen damit man
schlimmeres verhindert vielen dank für
diese information und informationen
danke für alle antworten nach bonn
professor henry gestrickt und natürlich
alles gute ihnen auch in ihrem team der
virologie gerade in diesen
herausfordernden tagen und liebe
zuschauer unser corona kompakt das
finden sie auch immer im netz und zwar
bei youtube auf dem kanal der zdf heute
in jeder ausgabe haben wir einen
experten dabei für ihre persönlichen
fragen wie gerade gehörten die können
sie weiter schicken können nicht alle
beantwortet werden aber schicken sie
gerne an kroner kompakte zdf de das ist
die mail adresse